social media companies allowed all those
video clips of Hillary saying that there
was a this was a fraud election they
allowed her Clips to stay on but the
other side the moment they said no this
is uh you know you're just talking about
a conspiracy theory so Hillary Clinton's
you know loss wasn't a conspiracy theory
but Trump's was a conspiracy theory so
which conspiracy theory is allowed and
which one's not well you're asking me
social media policy I'm gonna punt on
that one I I think the American people
give social media too much of a hard
time
if you want to sit down in Silicon
Valley and say there's billions of
tweets and I've got to figure out which
one's violent which one's semi violent
break oh no you give me a break give me
a break so these are so you think that
they should sit down an American company
that's supposed to make money for
America and like and influences the
globe yeah and go under because they're
hiring dude who do you think they should
you're the same guy that said you can't
put a treat me like a dog and put a
muzzle on my mouth I'm gonna say
whatever I want then you can't silence
me you said that you said that on CNN
you said this that's what I'm saying I
think they should spend less time
silencing Pika unless that's what I'm
saying yeah unless yeah when you get
into suggesting violence and I mean
suggesting I don't mean I don't mean
asking for I think you're done I don't
think I I think you're done okay fair
enough I believe that Congress should be
saying these are American businesses
making a lot of money how do we make
their jobs more doable so then if you're
saying that to you can't put any
violence uh last week the current member
parliament of turkey got up and on his
Twitter account put a video of him
speaking saying if you can find a saying
hey Armenia let me remind you guys what
we did to you we're starting to lose
patience to you don't make us if we
wanted to to we can we can choose to
make you disappear off of history and
geography that's genocide that's
genocide and Twitter left it off no he
should be off oh so he should be off in
my opinion because you're advocating
violence well then that's the part where
you know the the again this is where
people lose trust in organizations who
say they're fair and then the American
people say you're full of [ __ ] you're
not fair you're taking sides yeah and
that's why people are losing a little
bit of trust in different institutions
look I have four kids you know family
when he got kids they'll come up to you
and they'll say you like him more and
you like her more and you like this more
and you like that more look I like to
talk sports with my younger son but I
like to talk you know we weird topics of
Science and stuff like that with my
oldest son I just like to hang out with
my oldest daughter because last time we
took around out because you know
Hurricane's sitting here whatever we
took her out because we took the other
guys to the Miami Dolphins game and
whatever the game was uh Buffalo Bills
sick game so she's like you're not
spending time with us we took her on a
date there's different things I like
with everybody but it's my job to try to
stay as neutral as possible whether I
agree with one of them or not right and
companies same way you have operations
operation says well sales people they
don't know [ __ ] they're breaking
everything and then sales says
operations they're so slow so that is
that is a sign of leadership and we have
a hard time doing that I think you're
exactly right I mean I mentioned
leadership before and the significance
of leadership I thought leadership would
decline in the age of social media
because people would just look at
different sources of information and
absorb them and then you realize you
know Senators members of Congress
presidents
uh Supreme Court Justices which is a
different story really still influence
people the way they should influence
people and let me give you a specific
example in a second is by saying let's
have a conversation so let's take the
wall if you're on one side you'd say the
wall keeps illegal immigrants out if
you're on the other side you say this is
a land of immigrants and this violates
the principles of what America is you
know a conversation might be let's talk
to let's talk to CBP Customs and Border
Patrol let's talk to immigration and say
are there parts of the border that are
particularly susceptible to illegal to
illegal immigrants that you have a
difficult time policing that a wall
makes sense on and so let's say there's
you know 120 miles where where experts
say yeah that would really be helpful I
would say well let's fund it there's a
compromise we're going to fund sum of a
wall but we're not gonna we're gonna not
gonna fund a wall in areas where maybe
this is not that significant a problem
they're okay done we finished that
because of course you agree with me we
finished that in 30 seconds but but what
you're saying is but then the lack of
leadership is the fact that the borders
are a lady named Kamala Harris who's the
vice president refuses to go to the
border to see what's going on so you
lose again credibility you know if you
like listen what I said just a week ago
I said I have so much respect for uh for
a uh
China tells you if you go to Taiwan
we're going to do this you know she
shows up and then and you know uh
turkey says well and she shows up to
Armenia listens she's got some balls I
think she has more brass than Biden and
Kamala combined if you ask me that's
that's just but but to me is you don't
have the audacity to show up to the
Border listen of course the American
people don't believe you even even your
own side doesn't believe what you're
saying you've lost credibility
leadership is losing a lot of
credibility right now in many different
organ it's not just all the way at the
top at the White House VP FBI it's a lot
of different institutions and by the way
I don't think that's good you said
something very interesting uh I think
you were talking about the January 6th
where you you and lemon were going back
I don't know who was you were talking to
but the whole conversation was about the
fact that this is not a good idea the
fact that we keep pushing it the lady
sitting to your right I don't even know
what she was saying she was saying no we
should continue to push this because
maybe no more and she's saying this to
the host maybe what's going to happen is
if we keep doing this January 6
committee Trump's gonna get so upset
that all of a sudden he's gonna say
something on national television and or
this was Cuomo when Cuomo was done you
were with Como with the girl sitting to
your right and then Como's like no
that's not the right reasons to do this
and then you say I don't think we should
do this because it's getting America to
be more divided we keep getting more
divided these games are playing so so if
you like this clip and you want to watch
another one click right here and if you
want to watch the entire podcast click
right here
[Music]